[Música]
volvemos con ustedes para una consulta
con el especialista nos acompaña el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor pérez buen día para
usted gracias por acompañarnos y hoy
vamos a hablar de la diferencia entre
las tasas de mortalidad que están en la
región vamos a empezar con perú tiene la
tasa de mortalidad más alta de américa
latina- con 83 33 muertes por cada
100.000 habitantes y cómo podemos
entender esta cifra
y una de las cosas que hemos aprendido
en esta pandemia es que la medición de
la mortalidad ha sido distinta en varios
países y muchas veces no son comparables
el uno con el otro sin embargo la
situación de perú es una situación que
sin duda preocupa porque hay una alta el
número de muertos de fallecidos a pesar
de tener una de las cuarentenas más
prolongadas en esta pandemia y responde
mucho a las situaciones sociales y
medioambientales y las situaciones de
aglomeración de las personas y la
disciplina social la tasa de medición de
los casos también afecta este número
creciente de mortalidad y sin duda es
uno de los países más afectados
básicamente con sus condiciones
socioeconómicas
bueno según los datos oficiales doctor
chile viene en segundo lugar y esto ya
nos explica un poco el contexto de lo
que eso implica pero bueno considerando
la cantidad de habitantes que en chile y
que hace poco endurecieron las medidas
de cuarentena pues que podemos decir del
país austral
y recordemos angela que el chile al
principio tenía las menores tasas de
letalidad tanto así que se habló de un
pasaporte por ejemplo para reactivar la
economía y se hicieron unas medidas de
levantamiento temprano de las medidas de
restricción en esta en esta pandemia
digámoslo en términos coloquiales
estamos jugando el primer tiempo de un
partido y saber que se hacían los 15 a
los 20 minutos no predecía que iba a ser
al final del partido necesitamos un
tiempo para saber cómo hacer realmente
el comportamiento la situación de chile
es una situación que lo obligó a ser
mayor restricciones de confinamiento y
per cápita el número de fallecidos pues
es un número muy importante básicamente
concentrado en los suburbios de las
grandes ciudades en las partes
periféricas y realmente se relaciona con
la condición y con la dinámica la
interacción humana y entre tanto doctora
argentina por el contrario tiene una
tasa de mortalidad muy baja y solamente
presenta 6 mil 300 muertes
que han hecho ellos diferente
probablemente no es que haya algo
diferente sino que estamos viendo el
minuto 35 el partido es decir no sabemos
que el comportamiento va a ser así todo
el tiempo o simplemente se está
ralentizando el número de fallecidos
en argentina también tienen las
cuarentenas más prolongadas del mundo es
una de las más prolongadas en américa
latina se han hecho muchas medidas
restrictivas y pueden ser exitosas
recordemos que aquí el número de
mortalidad y lo importante es que no
haya colapso al sistema de salud es
decir es inevitable que vayan al
pacientes fallecidos por la pandemia
pero hay unas muertas que son evitables
o muertes que pueden suceder porque no
hay camas de contención porque no hay
cantidades porque todos están ocupados
es exceso de mortalidad sería lo que es
un desastre para los gobiernos y países
como colombia como argentina no han
tenido ese colapso en el sistema de
salud pero inevitablemente van a tener
los fallecimientos la situación de
argentina se relaciona sus medidas de
confinamiento temprano ya que han
mantenido las miras restrictivas a
través del tiempo
doctor cuál es la diferencia de
mortalidad en las regiones de américa
latina' comparada con europa y con eeuu
cómo podemos entender esas diferencias
sin duda a países como españa italia son
los que tienen el mayor número de
mortalidad por millón de habitantes y
eso se puede explicar es porque en el
momento que aparece la pandemia
realmente no conocíamos nada y la
enfermedad no sabíamos cómo se trataba
no sabíamos el comportamiento cuando
llegue a europa no tienen preparado el
sistema de salud y eso hace que el
número de mortalidad sea un número
excesivo de lo que pasó en españa italia
lo que pasa en américa del sur es que
pasaron al menos tres o cuatro meses
donde se preparó un poco mejor para
poder tener mejores sistemas de salud
para evitar el colapso sin embargo pues
el número de muertos también es una
muerte que también se relaciona con la
dinámica y la iniquidad social que hay
en nuestras regiones y lo de eeuu es que
es un gran país que tiene varios
sectores y el comportamiento pandémico
está en la región norte en la región sur
comportándose en la región norte similar
a italia en nueva york que ya está en
descenso y en ascenso lo que está
pasando en la parte sur de eeuu es decir
que es un comportamiento disímil por sus
características geográficas y social
y la real la calidad va a sucederse y
vamos a conocerle en un tiempo después
aquí lo importante es disminuir la que
es reduciendo la interacción física
manteniendo las medidas de higiene y la
protección con un cumplido casi todo el
tiempo doctor gracias por sus
recomendaciones y que tenga un feliz día
y a usted que nos ve desde casa recuerde
lavarse las manos y en lo posible
quedarse en casa buen día siga con
france 24
[Música]